there be that man who just entered you
know that is which one chief the man in
the hat
[Music]
that's simon the likable i don't care
what his name is chief i like him
everybody at some point in their life
has met someone who they would consider
to be truly likable
[Music]
like in the upper
99.9 percentile of likability these are
the types of people who when you talk to
them you feel understood you feel like
they're really listening they value you
as a human being and they see the best
in you no matter where these types of
people go it seems like they have
friends it seems like people tend to
celebrate them and elevate them to this
deity status
and it sounds kind of crazy but that's
why it's so rare i feel like i can only
name like three or four people i have
ever met who fit that description and it
seems like the more likable of a person
you are the more the world opens up to
you you know people just enjoy being
around you they always want to invite
you to things they want you part of
their company they give you promotions
and you can look at that and say well
that's not fair they don't deserve it
they're not more qualified than i am but
it doesn't make it any less true the
more likable of a person you are the
more people like you
you know some people are very likable
and other people are very difficult to
like and the people who are likable tend
to do better in almost every area of
life compared to people that no one
wants to be around
i've thought a lot about what makes
somebody likable what makes someone
somebody that people love being around
like what's the common theme and can we
implement those behaviors into our own
lives so that we're just generally more
likeable as a person now right off the
bat you might have some resistance
towards this proposition because you
might be thinking like oh why would you
want to be more likeable why would you
worry so much about what other people
think of you you're focusing on the
wrong thing you should focus on yourself
your own happiness and then people who
don't like it can screw off but i think
that's overly simplistic and foolish and
if you think that way you're not going
to get very far in life especially if
you already struggle with people and you
think that you know just being more of
yourself is going to help for some
reason it's like
how has that worked out for you
[Music]
because ultimately we're creatures of
habit what we think is just part of our
personality might just be a
conversational tick or bad habit that
we've picked up over
conditioning over the role that we
played in our friends circle or our
family and it could actually be making
us more abrasive of a person than
necessary for instance if you struggle
to make good eye contact with somebody
while you're talking to them and it's
just a habit that you have you tend to
like look down all the time if i told
you that if you made better eye contact
with people and you got more comfortable
with making eye contact with people
you're not gonna say that that is
somehow a betrayal of your personality
you wouldn't say that i'm telling you to
be someone that you're not i'm not
telling you to deny your god i'm just
saying that there are things that you do
that make a difference in how you are
perceived by others and i believe that
the most likable people
just do those things better than the
average person so in this video it's a
little bit of a different video i'm just
going to talk off the cuff about things
that i've noticed about the most likable
people i've ever met and then hopefully
we can try to figure out how to
implement some of those behaviors and
those mindsets to make us more likeable
and more enjoyable to be around so that
we can enrich our lives and have a
better time with being social and
interacting with people leaving people
better off than when we found them
so the first thing that you need to do
if you want to increase your likability
is that you have to realize that nobody
really cares about what you say
more than they care about how you make
them feel how you make people feel when
you're around them is the most important
thing that's the thing that leaves an
impression on people in fact 99 times
out of 100 people aren't going to really
remember the things that you said when
they go home after you interacted with
them they're going to remember how you
made them feel
good manners make good first impressions
they have a lot to do with how well
people like you a good example of this
is when somebody that you're talking to
is going on a rant about all of their
problems and they're really heated and
pissed off and they're you know they're
going on a monologue about all the
terrible things that have happened to
them throughout the day and you're
listening and you're kind of giving them
the time of day and then you try to
offer a piece of advice or an
observation or ask them a question but
they just sort of steamroll over you and
disregard anything that you say to
continue in their monologue
when that happens you kind of feel
dejected you kind of stop listening to
all the particulars of what they're
saying and the only thing that you're
left with is this feeling that they
don't really care about what you have to
say you know they don't really care
about your opinion they don't care about
you so f this person
every interaction that you have with
somebody is like that what people
remember about you is how you made them
feel it's the vibe that you give off is
it one that is encouraging and
empowering and collaborative reciprocal
or do you feel kind of expendable like
they don't really care about your unique
situation your unique perspective they
don't really care about any advice that
you have to give they might as well be
ranting at a brick wall here's another
example
say you're a guy and you're on a date
with some girl and you are talking about
all these things that you think are very
impressive you're saying a lot of words
you're talking about what you do for a
living you might be saying stuff
impressive like oh i have a six figure
income blah blah blah blah i have three
sisters something something something
and then once you realize that you've
been monologuing for a little bit too
long you ask routine questions to them
like oh how many sisters do you have
what's your favorite color blah blah
blah blah you know this goes back and
forth for an hour or two and she goes
home and while she's at home she was
thinking back on the date and she was
thinking to herself you know seems like
a nice guy but i just didn't feel that
spark like i didn't really feel like we
had chemistry
that spark
is everything that spark is what people
think of you
they don't think about all the little
things you said they don't really think
about all the things that you did or
what your job position is like no one
really cares what they care about is
that spark and that spark is the energy
you give off how do you make that person
feel when they're around you if you're
sitting there in an interaction with
somebody and you are tense and you are
performative then they're going to be
tense and performative as well the most
likable people on planet earth realize
this you know they put people at ease
because they're at ease that's what good
manners do they make everyone feel at
ease
they feel so comfortable with
conversation with eye contact with being
playful they realize that people like
you when you make them feel important
and valued that's what a boy likes he
wants to know he's appreciated you might
hear that and say okay what am i
supposed to do then am i supposed to
just be a pushover and just never voice
my opinion on things and make people
feel so special and comfortable and like
listen to all of their problems and
never talk about my problems or my life
and just be like a an interviewer that's
not what i'm saying and that's never the
way it works out because nine times out
of ten when you are genuinely interested
in someone else and you act genuinely
interested in someone else they feel
special and they end up liking you more
and when someone likes you they're more
likely to ask you questions about
yourself so it's almost like you have to
give first and then receive so another
thing you might say is what i'm just
supposed to pretend to be interested in
what they're saying like that's not very
genuine i thought that good connections
came from authenticity and honesty so if
i'm not honestly interested in what they
have to say then the entire friendship
is built on a facade but here's a weird
thing that i've noticed is it's almost
paradoxical because the people who are
most comfortable with who they are and
the life that they live are usually the
people who are least desperate to talk
about themselves because think about it
if you're insecure and you don't like
your life
then everything that you say
about your life or your job position or
what you tend to do
on saturdays you're subconsciously
hoping that the other person says oh
that's really cool oh wow
like you want so desperately for someone
to say wow you make six figures oh
that's such an interesting job that's
amazing but think about it everyone
thinks like you most people are insecure
so if you are that for people if you're
the person who says oh wow that's super
interesting tell me about that people
say oh my goodness let me tell you about
it this is awesome someone's listening
people are dying to be listened to
people are dying to be called by their
name to be looked at in the eye to feel
like man i don't know if that guy really
cares about me but i sure felt like he
did and that makes me feel good about
myself
that's the key to likability so i think
it all boils down to a few things if you
want to be the most likable person that
you can be the most likable version of
yourself
then firstly you have to live a life
that you like the more you're interested
in the world around you
the more interesting you become you have
to find yourself likable you have to
admire the things that you do on a
day-to-day basis or at least not
actively participate in something that
ruins your opinion of yourself because
if you dislike yourself then curiosity
in other people is hard to come by you
can't afford to be curious about other
people because you need their validation
you need them to validate you but people
who are secure in themselves and their
lifestyle will find that oh they don't
necessarily need people to comment on
their life because they like their life
so then they can actually have fun with
conversation and ask questions that they
find interesting and be interested in
the other person and as a result of that
the people that you're listening to will
say wow i like this person i want to ask
them questions about their life and then
that's when that reciprocity can get
going those are just some thoughts that
i've had the people that i think are the
most likable in life not only like
themselves or at least carry themselves
like somebody that they admire they
treat themselves with respect
but because of this they're able to go
into a room and not be desperate for
other people's approval
they can sit there very comfortably and
easily ask people follow-up questions
about their life and be genuinely
curious because there's a lot to learn
from people there's a lot of things that
people have gone through that you can't
imagine and that are genuinely
interesting and they can't wait to tell
you but no one ever asks
you know how to keep your friends you
got to be
got to be pretty considerate
look for the good in people give them
credit for being as
as straight as you are
yeah
it might work so yeah let me know what
you think of all that it's a little bit
more of a loose concept video i'd be
super interested in hearing what you've
observed about the most likable people
in your life you know when i say the
most likeable person you know someone
probably pops into your head what makes
them likable comment below and if you're
looking for less theoretical tips and
you want like step-by-step things that
you can do to make you more likeable
then one of the coolest books i've ever
read is the like switch by jack shafer
is basically an ex-fbi agent's guide to
making people like you and winning
people over based on hard-won evidence
that the fbi uses to actually convert
foreign agents into the fbi it's wild
and i highly recommend listening to the
audiobook version on audible which is
today's video sponsor because that's how
i enjoyed the book and for those of you
who don't know audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
and audiobooks all in one place if
you're interested in self-improvement
and just being a more knowledgeable
human being in general then audible is
kind of a no-brainer because it is by
far the best app for listening to
audiobooks and basically just inputting
some of the most valuable and timeless
insights ever recorded into your brain
while you're doing other things you
could be going for a walk cleaning your
house and you're soaking in timeless
information instead of listening to
lo-fi or whatever as an audible member
every single month you receive one
credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audiobook
forever if you ever cancel your audible
subscription for any reason at any point
you still keep your entire library of
audiobooks audible members also get
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible originals podcasts and exclusive
series so if you're interested in
joining me in becoming big brain and
just improving the quality of thoughts
that enter your brain by stealing from
other people's wisdom then if you use my
link in the description below to sign up
for audible you get a 30-day free trial
so make sure to take advantage of that
link head on over to
audible.com better ideas or just text
better ideas to 500 500 to get your free
30-day trial expand your mind learn
something new and as usual have a great
time and if you liked this video watch
my previous video it's not doing too
well in the algorithm and i really liked
that video it meant a lot to me and uh
it changed a lot of people's perspective
some people just straight up didn't get
it they're like
you just said eight minutes of
absolutely nothing but other people are
like dude this is some of the most
poetic [ __ ] i've ever seen so make up
your own mind on that i'll put a link
for that in the description below and a
big thank you to dimitrios who usually
edits my second channel videos he edited
this video so if you liked the editing
or you absolutely hated the editing on
this video be sure to let dimitrios know
is the first time i have not edited one
of my better ideas main channel videos
so
let me know how we did other than that
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video